[Music]
in sad time news Oh sad times time
submitted by four-leaf clover clover
with the bean clover jamali and talk
yeah
daredevil youtube recently died in a
waterfall accident oh thank goodness
yeah but it sound like you shouldn't be
multiple people that Oh multiple
youtubers died yeah are these the people
you know like they have those final
videos it's always like some guy like
standing with like the edge of his toes
off a building he wants to do a backflip
there or like it's like those type of
youtubers or content creators so this
channel is called high on life and they
just travel a lot and they do a lot of
like crazy [ __ ] oh they're trying to
make out with the rattlesnake I'll show
you a little highlight reel of what they
do
oh cool those videos are kind of dope
though Sarah really no that's really
cool I want to do with their life
oh [ __ ] this is amazing - oh that's
pretty tight
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
oh that's what that looks fun okay I was
picturing someone totally different I
was picturing like those [ __ ]
big-time
like for the views like you know like
[ __ ] [ __ ] like the ones that are
on the skyscrapers and they're just like
hanging off the edge like this this is
different this I see like it's like well
extreme extreme sports but like
well-produced
yeah they're all about like living life
and like just to the max and all that
stuff so this channel was started by
three people and three guys and two of
the three guys died because they were
filming something or was it just a freak
accident so I'm pretty sure they were
filming when they were doing this but
they were they were in Canada on this
Canadian waterfall and they were
swimming and the top of the waterfall so
this is what it looks like oh when one
of the guys girlfriend she ended up
getting picked up by a really strong
current and she got like she fell over
so when the boyfriend tried grabbing her
he also fell and hit the best friend
tried grabbing him he also my girlfriend
a cheap ass she was the first one that
three of them died just oh my god and
the other two were just trying to be
like good Samaritans and helping now and
then I'm dying to stew when he was here
according I don't know they don't
mention anything about I don't know that
farms big-ass big-ass [ __ ] water for
doing people oh that's so sad okay be
their names in a second they were just
being good citizens helping out yeah
actually I think it's a good friend well
the other friends are like best friends
since childhood
there's like super tight and then die
together
doing what they love adventures and
travel yeah
like if I was gonna die some way that's
like you want a waterfall dead most like
I lived as hard and as fast and as fun
as I could and then I died you know it's
like again makes dying young a little
bit worth it I mean it's never worth it
but yeah I know that Gary's saying
there's a dying doing what you love
anyway they were done it's not like they
came into their sorry job and they're
like I [ __ ] hate life in an anvil
falls on them fly from the sky he's dumb
black is there a blacksmith that's
working yeah but how come he always did
that in the cartoons because they wanted
they wanted to kill him like back in the
day they never fell from the sky he
dropped it sometimes they were just on
top of things when you lean and they
fall so I get what you're saying why why
was it up there yeah and why is it a cat
howl head upstairs two feet great with
four fingers yeah see I don't understand
and then the only thing that happens is
they get like this bar so it's Riker
Alexei and Megan that's yeah that sounds
like some adventurous names Riker for
sure yeah so do you Riker I Riker how
did she pass away she like she hit a
rock you know she slipped and water down
there maybe the the waterfall falling is
out it is an impact Hall like too high
of a waterfall
yeah that looked like a release I'm just
asking for the facts
oh I'm sorry she's dizzy smack into the
body or does she like live and
a [ __ ] snake came and bitter face off
like there's three people yeah well
there's a [ __ ] gargoyle that came and
ate the other two like what what
happened well I don't know if you could
survive a ninety eight foot drop
Oh ninety-eight foot I mean it looks
like is it like huge
that's all surprised you were because
sometimes it's the perspective you know
like when we go to like Eaton Canyon
like the the small waterfall they want
to does we I go take it from down here
and I'm like look how big that waterfall
is but yeah I get it okay I thought I
thought they were just dumb asses
showing off and then you know hey look
at me I'm a joke this waterfall I know
why all you died because you wanted to
do that but in this case yeah they're
just swim in there exploring they're
just being normal
adventurers yeah so yeah pretty sad
Juno's crazy I was looking up Ryker's
Instagram and apparently that whole high
on life group they were at that same
event that Nikki was in Vietnam oh so I
texted her on like hey this is crazy
did you know him and then she was like
yeah we were actually talking on
Instagram not that long ago she was like
I can't say yeah like she knew these
people these guys yeah it's pretty sad
so they have 1.1 million followers on
Instagram they have five hundred and
thirty three thousand subscribers on
YouTube and it's so sad they recently
uploaded a a video like the rest of the
guys yeah like they were really choked
up yeah that sucks because people want
to live a dangerous life because it it's
like you don't when you escape death
it's it's fun but when you actually die
then it's like oh man you know you know
you know you look up to these people I
wanna I want to pursue my life like that
and live that Ventris and then you see
them like really get hurt and injured or
like died and you're like oh maybe
that's not a good thing to do
so they didn't die doing what they
usually do
they were just swimming yeah but they
died adventuring and just going outside
but that's then that's how anyone can
die mm-hmm and I'm like I do a lot of
dangerous [ __ ] no you don't do you don't
do what's dangerous that you do you
[ __ ] say you're driving is danger you
do crazy
she says you go left are now gonna like
everybody out we wait till the camera
turns on to [ __ ] prove me wrong
real live you I feel looking so risky
you're so date you're not risky or
dangerous at all do you swim near
waterfalls
I love waterfalls and and I jump I jump
waterfalls 298 foot waterfall haven't
seen in 98 foot I don't know anyone that
does it except for that person that got
in the [ __ ] barrel and got out of the
Niagara Falls Houdini
yeah so there's a GoFundMe page that's
really sad yeah you're so young - I
think the right girl was 30 and then oh
yeah 28 and 29
I believe but even though even though
they died no I still want to go hiking
into the middle of nowhere or [ __ ] do
all the stuff that they did like if they
make it look so fun it's kind of like
the other story like somebody died on a
zipline right I feel like I'd still
zipline I'd still look at it be like not
me like everyone else is gonna die but
not me I kind of see it like that I'm
like if it's my time to go that's my
time ago [ __ ] but then when you do
about to die when you are upon
regretting it like you know who knows
I've never had that close call I bet you
that's what's gonna have a bad
[ __ ] all right [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ]
I'm bet you damn I don't know cuz then I
don't know there's anything I really
want oh there's a [ __ ] ton of stuff you
want like what am I gonna tell you if
you don't know
if you know what you walk you don't know
what you want some people just live life
like on the edge like we had a friend
that used to tattoo and every time we're
hanging out on the rooftop of this
building in the middle of downtown LA he
climbs off the side of the building like
spider-man do you know my friend Darion
yes you just all the time he's just like
on the side like he's just like for him
like like for a normal person it's like
even being on the edge and looking over
like that's already pretty crazy like
that's that's our danger zone his danger
zone is like this and he's like James
and then so like he could have easily
fell off I get any time and I feel like
someone like them like when they're
swimming like I would personally would
probably never swim on top of a
waterfall just cuz I know that there's a
strong current but they're just so used
to pushing the boundaries where they're
probably swimming really close and then
the strong currents came out of knowing
about it
their adrenaline levels are like like
what it takes to stimulate them is by
much higher than like the average person
yeah yeah they're so young
[Music]
[Music]